[Music]
jacob starts off this hour in phoenix hi
jacob how are you
good thanks for taking my call sure man
what's up
um i am actually going to get married at
the end of the school year we're gonna
move well she's in houston so i'm just
gonna move there and finish school
um we're kind of debating now is should
we
buy a house or should we just rent until
we get rid of
some debts that we have
yeah you're going to want to follow the
baby steps jacob and so i'll walk you
through those really quickly because
this is the way for you to build wealth
and so you want to do things in this
specific order
you want to start by saving a thousand
dollars and this is going to be your
starter emergency fund so that if you've
got uh you know your breaks go out you
get a flat tire you've got some cash to
cover that and you don't have to go
further into debt
then you're going to list all your debts
smallest to largest regardless of
interest rate and you're going to attack
those debts
one at a time pay them off cut up their
credit card close the account whatever
you have to do you pay minimums on the
rest and you continue to walk down
the debt snowball until all your debt is
paid off when you get all your debt paid
off you're out of school your school's
paid for in cash everything's covered
where you have no more debt
then you want to save three to six
months of expenses
for a fully funded emergency fund and
after that that's when we talk about
saving for a down payment on the house
we would tell you to do that anyway
jacob at any stage of life any age
but even i would just add the fact that
you're in school you're about to get
married you're going through a lot of
transition
and so you probably don't really know
what you want anyway in a house so even
if you
were debt-free i would still recommend
that you get out of school
with that without any debt and uh and
and and really figure out what you want
uh before you commit to a massive
purchase like that but you want to get
debt free have your fully funded
emergency fund get out of school
debt-free and then and then and then
talk about saving up for down payment on
a house jacob there's a lot of pressure
in our culture to immediately buy a
house
buy a house buy a house buy a house buy
houses you're throwing away rent you're
throwing away the money you're throwing
your money down a rat holes a renter
don't be a renter don't be a runner like
renters go to hell or something right
and so you you don't you don't want to
fall for all of that it causes people to
jump into a house because when you buy a
house and you've got no money
and you're in debt
all kinds of problems come crashing down
around your head and it's going to put a
stress on your new marriage
strain on your new marriage just rent
something inexpensive and clean up the
debt then when you don't have any
payments man
and you move into a house with no
payments and you move into a house and
after you close on the house you've
still got the rainy day fund of like 10
000 bucks or whatever it is sitting
there that put there's no stress moving
in the house now the home is a blessing
rather than a curse and we always say
yeah christie's right you need to get to
know each other you'll buy a different
house a year after marriage than you
will you know a week after marriage
takes about a year being married to know
how close to your mother-in-law